[Music]
the convict
19 pandemic has affected kenya's food
systems
directly through impacts on food supply
and demand
and indirectly through decreased
capacity to produce
and distribute food in response to that
the ministry of agriculture livestock
fisheries and cooperatives
is addressing food supply chain and
nutrition challenges
through the establishment of one million
kitchen gardens
in rural and urban households through
this 1 million kitchen gardens
the ministry is contributing to the big
four agenda
on the 100 food and nutrition security
by enabling households to maintain a
healthy diet
food safety is also an integral part of
food security
the ministry is therefore promoting good
agricultural practices
that are necessary for the production of
safe and healthy fruits and vegetables
in this video we will look at basic good
agricultural practices
that should be applied during production
and post-production
that help in reducing the risk of
microbial contamination of food
[Music]
agrochemicals are chemical products used
in agriculture to protect plants from
pests
and improve their growth they include
pesticides insecticides herbicides
fungicides nematicides and fertilizers
these agrochemicals are toxic to both
humans and pests
therefore extra precaution must be taken
when purchasing
transporting handling storing and
disposing them agrochemicals should
always be purchased at an
accredited source with a pcpb
license when purchasing always remember
to check the expiry date
manufacturing date and the mixing ratio
how do i put on my protective gear
which one comes first
so to put on my protective gear
i need to start
systematically
so i start off
with the overall after putting
on the overall then
i put on
gum boots then
the goggles i put on
the mask after putting on the nut mask
i put on the headgear
and finally my gloves
while wearing my gum boots
i make sure the overall
is over the gum boots to avoid
chemical dripping into
my legs same with when i'm wearing my
gloves
i make sure that the gloves are worn
under the sleeves then
i am ready to mix my chemicals
different formulations are done
differently they are those
which are in liquid form if i'm going to
mix in liquid form
extra care needs to be taken because
but it's very easy for spillage
on my skin so what i need to do
i need to put everything ready the water
the measuring that i'm going to use
i need to put aside the spillage kit
under the spillage kit i need
a small bucket
i need soil or sawdust
or sand i need
a brush and i need a broom
for spillage kit this should be on
standby
as i do my mixing
now in the process of doing
the liquid formulation i take my
knapsack
and put one third of water into the
the reason i'm putting water fast is
because
i'm avoiding the concentrated
chemical getting into the outlet
because if i put the chemical first
and it gets into the outlet the moment i
start spraying
i will cause damage to the target
of spray so after putting
the water i measure
the recommended quantity making sure i
do not
under dose or overdose then i add
into the knapsack then agitate
the knapsack after agitating the
knapsack
i triple rinse the measuring jar
and empty into the knapsack
after triple rinsing and emptying into
the knapsack
i fill up the remaining parts with water
agitate then now
i am ready to spray
harvesting at the right time can have a
big impact on crop yield
and quality there are different
harvesting styles depending on the type
of plant
in this video we will learn how to
properly harvest vegetables
in a kitchen garden this is a corn
garden
in our corn garden we have strawberries
cauli kales
spinach and kales
tsukumawiki the nomos kumawiki this is a
thousand heads
we are going to do harvesting
of some of the vegetables today early
morning harvesting
is best for most vegetable crops when
harvesting greens for salads or cooking
the best picking time is before 9 a.m
when the sun is too hot the plants will
have wilted
and that makes them difficult to prepare
so we are going to have an open basket
with the
which is well aerated so that our
vegetables remain fresh
and then we are also going to use a
sharp knife
we are using a sharp knife because we
want to cause
minimum damage to the plant if you use a
plant knife or use the hand it will
cause a lot of damage to the plant
and it will take a lot of time and
nutrients to heal
it may also be a source of contamination
for bacteria for diseases like bacterial
wealth
and the whole plant may die so
hold your knife we are going to harvest
the kali kales
the caulicells can be harvested once
they have from six
to eight leaves so we are going to
harvest
make sure you cut all the outer leaves
as you harvest you put in your
hydrated basket it could be woven or
plastic like
this one of mine continue harvesting
as you harvest you leave the stalks two
inches from the plant
to prevent diseases and
injuring the plant so that the plant
doesn't waste nutrients healing the
wound
eventually these left stocks will dry
off and just for
fall naturally and the plant will
continue growing
we have left at least four leaves you
leave at least four leaves
this these four big leaves are what we
are likely to harvest
next time so don't cut all the leaves
and leave the small ones
only remember the plant manufactures its
food through the leaves so you must
leave enough foods
enough leaves for the plant to
manufacture its food
continue like that until you do the
whole garden
so that next time you come you can
harvest again
alternatively you could do a few plants
next time a few plants
and continue with that kind of sequence
next time you're harvesting again
so that is our harvested plant i've left
at least
four big leaves so that the plant
continues maturing food
manufacturing food if you continue
harvesting like
that you're also giving enough space for
the new leaves to grow
harvest often some vegetables mature
very fast
therefore it is a good idea to stay on
top of harvesting
frequent harvesting can result in higher
quality
and better tasting vegetables it can
also encourage a large yield
and reduce wastage due to over mature
produce
so our our spinach now is well harvested
and we continue with that process the
remaining leaves can be harvested
like after two weeks or even one week
just make sure you leave at least three
to four leaves
that you can have us next time so we're
actually taking
all uh kenyans who would be then
interested to set up their their own
kitchen gardens
or home-based gardens within the
confines of their homes
we would then be able to you know
provide big technical support
be it technical and also
you know input support to the families
that may not afford
to to buy for themselves from this
tutorial it is our hope that you will
apply
good agricultural practices and enjoy a
constant supply
of safe and nutritious vegetables fruits
and spices
for you and your family in case you need
more
information kindly log on to
[Music]
www.kilimore.go.ke
you